welcome to this video versus a mammogram
off l marmalade so what do we get here
some English going to go with D for and
on it not yet yeah so what we I is
playing the tower right no now is there
for the semi tirage also interesting
opening and take it go 44 I think here
and showed g5s turn this is the usual
way to play this opening and 27 now 27
interesting so maybe night over to d3
here I'm not sure that feels a bit
strange now that Bishop
where do I put it yeah they normally
play f6 quindi 7s not a move I'm
unfamiliar with it looks yeah it looks
interesting ask my bishop what it is
doing okay lets rule out the night 2d 3d
one protecting it to
you know we can I had to move it anyway
I just wonder well let's start with that
move maybe it's going to do five anyway
no it doesn't okay here my 85 coming
okay of course he wants to trade the
bishop that makes perfect sense ok let's
take go for Quincy for Queen trade would
be very welcome okay that's quite an
aggressive way to do it so Quincy for is
going Queen f5 quite clearly the 95 but
that looks it should be a bit little bit
better for me this position or not where
is he going is karrueche five it's got
Ruby five after the trade that's it's
very important
I thought after night c5 text takes he
had to concede to a queen trade if he
doesn't have to do that it's a bit bit
awkward huh shoot it's Nets not good
hmm
right was an oppression and then 95
okay let's do that anyway it's a thought
for too long by a vet chalky position
rupee 5pm I really had I didn't see that
move before hand that's really an
essential if he has to trade Quincy is
just in very bad shape but this is of
course okay so let's see can I queen bee
three maybe now I will take and put it
only five
hmm yeah don't still know queen bee
three could take and put 95 on the end
still I have ready to be solid position
here I think don't think it should be a
huge issue okay clean I don't get the
point at the mode t3 or what exactly I
know then you can take 95 what is this
year 95 again
midas this is annoying now so let's see
look sexy too yeah if you have if you
lose time we move quickly you will
blunder at one point at least I quite
often do I can take on e2 now yep check
okay may I have slide hopes because his
slightly weakened king but he can pin me
on the second rank after the caption e2
Jack I can Quinn Quinn seat or something
was pretty good check g7 time burning
maybe open this up
chicks are there is no bishop age six or
something yeah it would be cured and
queen on the second was easier you can
still do that looks in a Quincy too it's
just wrong okay
feels like I should have some kind of
chances here a little bit like could
have played it easier shot simply and
everything but maybe it's still just
winning that's probably still just
winning and even have a check chan that
was just bad right check check check
it's not even trying to win one position
I know a six no check
Jim and it continues and continues and
continuous check oops yeah it's still a
long time even though is playing it
really badly hey but that's the thing
with this time control check check check
check special actually check white 458
time of course just before I can
perpetual him okay yeah but it didn't
play it well really so I mean okay maybe
a draw would have been fine because he
totally screwed this position of which
was completely and easily winning but
rite throughout right around here I
really didn't find anything which
resembles a good plan so yeah it's got
this pressure on the pawn only tool Jim
well as some of that will be fired but I
didn't see anything better it's probably
not that bad the engine says equal now
when it isn't it did it's kind of
uncomfortable to play and of course he
have blundered rookie too and she found
yeah computer is very just stating my
kia equal yeah maybe yeah i mean porn is
bad here okay but his king is also not
great might be might be okay
and a blonde Jackie check yeah now he
could just ring winning in various
simple ways Quincy to for example queen
bee to that is all very easily winning
check okay wait he had some chance here
95 was poz meeting me and so on but I
don't know check then probably sell the
winds and the check check check check
check blonde at that one and two at the
end it it got to be got to be a draw
yeah Jackie we are already this is
already channel okay I couldn't do it in
the time yeah I don't know what is
opening how this is played the only
thing that I do know is i knew the f6 is
the normal move then they go here and go
III bishops III this kind of thing and
on no Queen D sound mmm Bishop feels a
bit a bit out there on g5 I don't know
what's best here maybe the night
maneuver it's not it's not right it's
quite often the way it displayed going
up to see 5 unsure at least that's clear
that the way it went it was okay for him
yeah right here black is definitely okay
I think he's quite active and it's
nothing nothing great maybe actually
maybe this is wrong I mean Bishop g5 is
coming maybe in this move like this and
this could be an idea if if I get
something like that I'm kind of okay
with that
preparing like this preparing before
maybe this is a slight edge but snap
doesn't feel doesn't feel great yeah I
don't know that opening he really got a
good position there okay well thanks for
watching